reverse huh that's irony for you so uh
what should we call this brave new world
that you've whipped up for us I was
thinking flashpoint so you don't want
this you may have figured out a way to
dampen my speed with this glass cage but
I will get out of here and I will
destroy your life flash one way or the
other
no you won't you're never getting out of
here and never gonna hurt anybody ever
again I have everything back that you
took from me
I have everything zoom took I'm finally
free home this isn't your home Barry
this is a mirage a fiction that will end
us both unless you let me the hell out
of this thing Wow you know listening fun
why would I want to get out of here I'm
hold here there's even a flash so I
don't have to be yeah who is this
dashing young speedster huh do you know
you didn't care while you sit around and
hide like a lost lonely little boy
fighting someone else risk their life to
protect the city our common enemy is
coming for us both
what common enemy is that time it's
already screwing with you and everyone
you love him pretty soon it's gonna take
me right down along with you
Wow you know he's got some nerve I'll
give you that warning me about messing
with other people's lives you know the
whole reason I did this is because of
what you did to my life to my family to
my mother one day soon Barry
you'll be begging me to kill her again
the flash season premiere this Tuesday
at 8/7 central hey youtubers is charlie
the flash is back
last big clip before we get the episode
tomorrow we get to listen to the reverse
slash tell Barry why he's so terrible
flashpoint style it's all about the
reverse flash coining the phrase
flashpoint in explaining to Barry
exactly what's going to be happening to
him because if there's one thing that
Barry is really bad about it's about
doing the math when it comes to making
decisions like this like everything
seems fine so that must mean that
everything is OK nothing bad will happen
because of what I did
I righted a wrong you murdered my mother
so I went back and saved her I fixed
what zoom did everything is wonderful
so charting the timeline from the season
2 finale they said it's been about three
months when we first meet Barry he's
been living with his parents who were
alive now we don't really learn from
this clip whether or not he actually
knows that Wally is the new version of
the flash it sounds like he's not
because I think they want to have that
moment during the first episode where he
sees Wally and just kind of chuckles at
the universe like he knows there's
another flash but it sounds like he
hasn't actually met him in person yet
but thankfully big belly burger is not
subject to flashpoint you don't want
this like he's been feeding him for
these three months and he says he's
never getting out of there so this
raises more questions than it answers is
it going to be some kind of Silence of
the Lambs thing for the rest of his life
like what is Barry's long-term plan the
way Grant Gustin talked about it at
Comic Con is that he has absolutely no
plan at all he's in a very
one-day-at-a-time mode just kind of
drunk on happiness with his parents
being alive like just enjoying their
presence but the way they've been
talking about the future episodes like
they've revealed the description of the
third episode I talked about how that's
like a big Jessie quick episode it's
going to be awesome but it makes it
sound like flashpoint will be over by
the time we get to it so it seems like
the way they're billing flashpoint on
the flash is that it'll be like a
two-hour event where like this first
hour will let you see the world of
flashpoint like look at all the
craziness look at everything that's
different then the second part of that
will be like the terrible dire
consequences manifesting
oh my god we have to fix this of all the
things that'll stick I wonder if they'll
carry forward the joke about Barry
keeping the reverse-flash locked up in
his basement
for three months we don't really know
where this is either it's probably not
under STAR Labs because that seems like
the headquarters for Cisco's company who
you know like billionaire Cisco so
reverse-flash torture basement must be
in some other place during the city like
last season we have the cool basement
with the wormhole I'm just expecting to
see a couple new cool rooms inside STAR
Labs sabotage lair is also another big
place too we've seen some pictures from
behind the scenes so don't know if we'll
get teased with that before flashpoint
is over or after because of all the
things that I think will stick after
flashpoint gets fixed I think there'll
be the new speedsters I think they'll be
the dynamic between the characters like
Cisco will go back to being the fun
Cisco but like the type of energy
between Barry and iris like her not
having grown up inside the same house
with him that will stick so it'll be
less creepy when he pursues her because
they kind of grew up like brother and
sister so you're like well aren't they
supposed to get married and have kids
isn't that kind of weird it's almost
like getting married to your sister so I
think they're using flashpoint to kind
of like fix that a little bit to make a
little bit easier for them to actually
be together and then Sabbat are in dr.
alchemy because it seems like dr.
alchemy was teased in the first couple
of episodes when we got that very first
trailer but they might do mr. element
and turn him into dr. alchemy mr.
element is like the second version of
dr. alchemy but his name was mr. element
even though technically he is a doctor
alchemy but I think that's who Tom
Felton's character is playing but really
the whole deal with these first two
episodes is just having fun with the
idea flashpoint like oh this is cool
look at all these different things then
oh flashpoint we have to fix this
at the very end but that one reverse
flash line just land so well in that
clip by the end of this you'll be
begging me to kill your mother again
that's the moment Barry double takes
because in this moment here Barry's just
laughing at everything the reverse-flash
is saying like I've fixed all this
that you broke like he's not even
listening to what the reverse-flash is
saying and just to put this into
perspective
the most part the reverse-flash that you
know that you Barth on from season one
had been living in that timeline for ten
plus years so he was effectively a
different character this version of you
Barth on is the person who had just come
back to kill young Barry and then ended
up trying to kill his mother so he still
passionately hates Barry but he's not
wrong
in order to fix flashpoint this Barry is
going to have to go back to that moment
during the season one finale until the
other version of himself dude do not
don't do this
you can't save mom so think of like the
first two episodes is like a two-hour
flash movie just called live-action
flashpoint so it's going to be a lot of
fun and there will be a new round of the
giveaway that'll start so I'll actually
just go ahead and start it now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'll
just remind everyone when I post my
episode 1 video after the episode airs
so I'm going to try to work out the
schedule this week because there's still
some Luke Cage do there's still agents
of shield arrow is premiering so there's
a whole bunch of stuff that's happening
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that superhero Fight
Club trailer again and you can click
here for all my flash videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight